وينضم الينا من بيروت العميد الياسحنا
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي مرحبا بك
عميد الياس حنا اذا لدينا الان مجموعتان
تعلنان عن نفسهما
كمجموعات مواليه لاوكرانيا في داخل
المتطوعين وفيلق حريه روسيا
يعني كيف يمكن تقييم هذا الامر
هي احدى الوسائل المهمه لنقل الحرب الى
الداخل الروسي لماذا لانه هي الاسهل في
هذه المنطقه شبيكينو من مقاطعه بيلجورود
هي الاقل كلفه هي الاسهل هي الاقرب
والاكثر امكانيه وبالتالي القدره للحكومه
الاوكرانيه على النكران ولكن هذا الامر لا
يحصل الا اذا كان هناك استعدادات سابقه
يعني اليوم هذه الفيالق لا يمكن ان تجهز
وتدرب الا اذا عرفت طبيعه الارض والمنطقه
منذ وقت طويل فاذا نحن امام ظرف معين الا
وهو الاستعداد لهجوم الاوكراني كما قال
الرئيس
اننا جاهزون فاذا هذا ظرف معين ومهم جدا
وله اهداف عديده ولكن بالحديث عن الهجوم
الاوكراني المضاد وحديث المسؤولين
العسكريين الاوكرانيين عن ان اوكرانيا
ستسترد مالي اوكرانيا
تفهم ان الهجوم ربما سيستهدف الاراضي
الاوكرانيه
التي تحتلها روسيا لماذا الذهاب باتجاه
بيلجورود
هي العمليه التكتيكيه ال سي تحضيرا للهدف
الاكبر يعني نستذكر ماذا قالت ماذا قالت
الحكومه الاوكرانيه قبيله استرداد كانت
تركز دائما على الهجوم في خرسون وهذا بهدف
الخداع العسكري وبالتالي اتى الهجوم في
المنطقه الاضعف فاذا اليوم اذا اخذنا ما
يجري في ربطناه بما جرى في موسكو
والمسيرات فوق الكرملين القصف نضال القصف
على ماريوبول والقصف على
المرفا كل هذه الامور يقال عنها بالعلم
العسكري هي تحضيرا او شيبينغ جراوند هي
تحضيرا للمعركه القادمه لالهاء العدو وخلق
امكنه كثيره للخداع وبالتالي التركيز على
منطقه اساسيه وقد تكون المنطقه ال سي يعني
من ذا بيولوجيا ميليتو بول توكماك وباتجاه
البري الروسي وهنا سؤال هل هذه
الاستراتيجيه التي تتبعها اوكرانيا ناجحه
باعتقادك يمكن ان تؤتي ثمارها
كل الاستراتيجيات توضع وليس بالطبع
وبالتاكيد ان تنجح هذه الاستراتيجيات
الرئيس بوتين لديه استراتيجيه كبرى 22
شباط 2022 هي اليوم الاهداف لم تتحقق ككل
وانتقلت الحرب الى الاراضي الروسيه ليس
بالتاكيد ان تكون الحرب ناجحه وهذا ما
قاله البارحه الرئيس زلينسكي
نحن لا نعرف سيكون الثمن كبيرا دائما
الاستراتيجيات تطبق وتنفذ والواقع هو الذي
يعكس صحه او عدم صحه هذه الاستراتيجيات
والا كل من يرسم استراتيجيه ينتصر في مكان
ما ولا يعود هناك من خاسر ال سي شكرا
جزيلا لك من بيروت العميد الياس حنا
الخبير والعسكري والاستراتيجي